a 28 profesores se les preguntó sobre su
curso favorito siete de ellos dijeron
historia uno dijo matemáticas son muy
pocos los matemáticas son muy muy
divertidas un profesor dijo física 10
dijeron geometría y 9 dijeron lenguaje
vamos a crear un gráfico de barras
mostrando los cursos favoritos de todos
así es que empecemos identificando
nuestro diagrama aquí tendremos en este
eje vertical el número de profesores y
en el eje horizontal tendremos los
cursos vamos a empezar por matemáticas
subiremos y bajaremos estas columnas de
tal manera que lleguemos al número con
cada uno de los cursos en los que los
profesores dijeron que estas eran sus
materias favoritas y empecemos con
matemáticas con matemáticas nos dijeron
un profesor que su materia favorita lo
llevamos al 1
lenguaje el lenguaje vamos a buscar
nueve profesores dijeron lenguaje vamos
a subir esta barra hasta llegar al
número nueve
geometría donde quedo geometría
geometría 10 profesores dijeron que
geometría entonces esta barra subida un
poco más que la anterior que tenía nueve
física sólo hay uno con física la física
también es divertida no sé por qué
salieron estos datos así y en la
historia tendremos siete profesores que
dijeron historia vamos a llevar la barra
hasta el número siete y de esta manera
se ve nuestro diagrama de barras vamos a
verificar nuestra respuesta
es correcta